so I'm going to come back to box map this prototype
app to
See how we can answer this question. So
the first one
we're not getting into.
the basics of probability
and this is
example 1
okay.
How many questions we have? We have one two, three. So for number one.
answer one
the easy Reason by the way develop this app is because
we can I can type mathematically without
any scribbling.
so
here's how you
type in this this is how you set notation.
I want you to focus here. Okay, I'm gonna write the code for here, but I
want you to pay attention here.
They ask for a set s so s equals.
Okay, that's
containing
all of the outcomes
of
the
experiments of rolling your dice. Let me start with a simple
example.
if you were flipping a coin
once if you had one experiment then your
sample space would look like this.
This is this is set notation.
Okay, this is your set.
the collection and the curly bracket
means that you know, this is what you have.
You have a heads.
and the tail
Okay.
Now I'm going to save us time.
and
show you the entire sample set because there are
36 of them and I don't want to type them all one by one.
So the answer to that question.
is the following
and I want you to see tell me if we can understand the notation
What's Happening Here?
So we have one one we have one two.
We have one three. What does this mean?
the first one
this is not 11. This is one one.
You roll a dice?
And your outcome is you get one one.
in each dice
you roll the die again. You get one in one
dice to get two on the other dice.
All the way up to where you have six.
On this thighs and that dies.
so this
Is set notation by the way if you haven't seen it before.
Basically, this is how mathematically Express the
situation.
So here we have six in each dice. That's
this one over here six and six
Okay, a family rise of stuff with this because we will do an exercise involving
this type of notation.
Then it says
you set notation.
to less the event e
where the die is rolled and the outcomes at outcomes add
up to six.
Now I want you to think about this.
Look at this set.
how many of these add up to six so one and plus one
is two
That's not it. So the set will not let me actually write the
the outer part
and help you guess what should go in here next?
Okay, so what should go here?
So whatever goes in here you just keep in mind that the numbers.
Must add up to six for example. Well, I
don't want to give you an example. This is what I want to jump to.
Slack
and show you how we will proceed with exercises.
So on slack, there's a channel.
called statistics probability Theory and r
I want everyone to join.
Here's the link again.
And I want you to send me the answer.
Send me the answer to this small exercise.
And you can choose to type in the answer you can choose into.
Maybe right on a piece of paper and send me the picture.
or
you know, however you want to send it, but send it to me
privately so I can
track your progress. We'll do this would spend five minutes
on this no more and then I'll show you the answer.
Just want to get your family with a set notation.
Who's working on the exercise if you're working on the exercise type and working?
I want to see how many of you are actually participating by the way mathematics is
not a spectator sport.
You do not want to be a spectator if you don't.
the way your brain works when you're learning is if
you don't like
do the work.
Like the way you the wiring of your brain?
Has been his design.
If you don't like physically.
Do the work.
It won't be as effective. Elena says I am listening but cannot
currently participate that's okay, but hopefully maybe by the
way this session is being recorded. So once maybe in your
free time, you can rewatch this video and do the exercise
but I strongly recommend that you try we will only
spend five minutes on it.
But let get your Mighty think about how
you should go about it. Just keep in mind that the points
must add up to six.
So for example, you wouldn't put one one one.
It's as up to two.
To try that again and no cheating. Don't try
to go don't Google this. Okay. This is not an exam. This is only
to put your mind in a state that you were you.
You know.
That encourages you and motivates you to.
Look for this solution.
excellent
By the way people if necessary.
We can add more days to the workshop. My goal here is to
help you learn not.
cram, and
make you anxious
excellent
Okay.
Let's go ahead and solve this problem together.
And I want you to help you do this. Okay?
So I'm gonna come down here which numbers
add up to six like which points we
have one. One two, one three one plus one is two that's
not it.
OnePlus 3
That's 4 that's not it. How about one
and five that adds up
to six? So let's put that in there one and five.
one and five
Okay.
Which one which one? Can we put
in here? Not this one? Not this one. How about
Two plus four two and four. I'm gonna put one for in there.
What about
let's see.
33 thank you Casey 33. That's another one
three plus three adds up to six.
And then we have four 42. That's 4 plus
2.
4 and 2
and then we have what else do
we have?
Five and one, right?
Thank you. Okay, see five and one.
And then what else do we have?
I think that's it.
I hope I haven't missed any.
so we have
one two three, four five
So that's our event space.
This is a subset of that.
You're learning two things by the way, you're learning both set theory and
probabilities here. Now. This is a subset of that. What does that mean? What does
it mean for for something to be a subset of something else? It means
that this
Set contains some of the elements of this
set.
Okay, not vice versa.
Okay, this set has all of the elements of
this set, but this set has a subset of the
elements of this set, but that's it.
So that's it for question 2.
Then we have question 3. What is the probability of event e in
the sample space this is
I'm going to give you hint.
I'm Gonna Give You hint.
I'll go back to.
this slide
if you have six sides on a dice.
What is it? Probably that you would get a 3?
if you roll the dice once one out of six
Each face on the dice gets one.
You know.
like
I don't want to use any word by mistake but
like the chances one out of six.
no dice gets
has some magical power like you
I know some people they take a dough Dice and they blow into
their fist or
They do some magical movement.
Hoping that if they roll the dice, they'll get lucky and the stars are lying
and get a sex. It's not gonna work that way.
You get one out of six?
Unless you know if unless, you know something about weight
distribution and physics like those expert Casino
players, but blowing into your face
not gonna change it's gonna be one over six. So now that you
know, this is it gonna help you figure out this question for answer number
three.
It's a simple fraction.
What is the size of 5? Excuse me? What are the size of e how many
elements do we have in five? One, two, three, four five?
Very funny Alex, or maybe you could be lucky but for for
the for most people the probability
will will not change for them.
Okay, how many items do we have in the set e five?
How many items do you have in this sets? S36?
Well, there's your answer the answer.
Two question three. What is the probability?
of these numbers appearing
out of these numbers is
five
out of 36
Okay, 5 over 36 which adds up
to?
This number now this number is important. I'll tell you
why.
Remember that probability is a number between 0 and
1.
You can think about one big 100 percent and if we turn
this into percentage, it will be 30% It's the probability that these
numbers will come.
you will get these numbers out of
all the other possibilities is
13.30 or 13 percent almost 14%
if you round up.
then notation for probability is this
p
What is my?
the probability of E
That's what this is. No this notation.
P has to be uppercase
P has to be application if you want to if you want to express this
idea the probability of e happening.
given this
Given, this is the sample sample size is 0.13.
So for example if you are betting on a number on a
dice.
You want to bet on you? Should you should you should you can
put this to your advantage like you can sit down and write them down and see which
subset.
What event is a subset of this apple said what subset
of the sample space will have more elements?
If it has more elements elements, I said elephants the
more elements. There are in the subset the higher
the probability.
And guess what people who work in casinos know
this and use it to their advantage.
Okay. Now this is just the basic.
example
But even knowing the basics will get you
far.